[Musik]
jetzt schon live wir sind live ja ganz
Deutschland Hallo
[Musik]
ich mal wie du gerade aussiehst verliebt
wo bist du ich sehe dich nicht
hey nein oh mein Gott ich werde glaube
ich gerade bekämpft ich bin kurz zum Tot
[Musik]
ach du scheiße wie geht das denn jetzt
Luca concrafter hi hi hoffe
[Musik]
ich drücke ganze Zeit auf die linke
Maustaste da passiert nichts Digger du
musst du musst Linksklick gedrückt
halten so ich drücke immer auf neu gut
mein Fehler Story jo Leute bin gerade am
craften kommt rein
[Musik]
Bikini ne ja Dörfer in Minecraft sind so
Orte wo so
Menschenleben die schlaf jetzt aber
gerade wahrscheinlich
hier Sandra hier ich habe was für dich
komm her
[Musik]
ich komme nicht wieder raus
wenn du ein Item aufnehmen willst
[Musik]
zuallererst müssen wir uns wirklich um
irgendwas zu Essen kümmern das heißt wir
bauen uns erstmal eine Farm oder
vielleicht gibt's ja auch eine Farbe
guck mal hier vorne ist Heu guck mal
hier über diese Brote 5 Sekunden den
später
geklaut
der hat dir Brot 10 Minuten hat mir
gerade mein Brot geklaut
du legst dich nicht die Welt zum Essen
angeht mit mir an das war ein
Riesenfehler mein Brother jetzt geht's
aber ja ja ja ich habe doch gesehen ja
ja ja ja du
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was da war gerade wieder rechts der
schwarze Panther
ja der hat schon wieder vorbei
sag mal lass die Häuser stehen von den
Leuten
wir gehen jetzt erstmal schlafen dafür
klauen wir uns jetzt Betten aus den
Häusern hier
Häuser stehen von den Leuten kann man
auch das Pferd reiten ja genauso wie du
mich
dafür brauchen wir mal einen Sattel Sana
du musst das nicht abbauen guck mal es
gibt doch die Türen setzen wir den Zaun
wieder hierhin bitte
[Musik]
nicht wegschmeißen mal
kannst du mir pushe push the door please
du kannst doch wohl eine Tür aufmachen
hier die Tür von unserem Haus
[Musik]
ja weg craften ja paar Dinge müssen
getan werden ich springe jetzt runter
ich sag dir wenn du nachkommst okay
bis gleich
wenn ich sterbe Schatzi hast du
du machst Podcast allein weiter okay
[Musik]
bei uns sind doch direkt Creeper warte
okay
[Musik]
Ciao Laser du Bastard Skyblock kommt
hey
ich will
[Musik]
ich will hier verursachen abbauen
ich bin obdachlos bitte hilf mir das
Geld ist alles was ich habe zeigt
Sixpacks für drei Euro
die hat gerade jemand Geld gespendet und
hat gesagt dass er obdachlos ist und
dass die 3 € die er mir gespendet hat
das einzige Geld und was er hat und er
will mein Sixpack sehen
kannst du mal kurz hier das Kohle
abbauen sondern hier
das dauert ja ewig Luca
Sandra
ach so ich habe heute Angst benutzt
sorry
es tut mir leid Pocahontas du brauchst
doch immer nicht die Cola
Bier
was das da unten das hier
[Musik]
nein nein nein nein
nein nein
oh mein Gott
da stehen bleibt genau da stehen
zu mir ja alles gut ich schieße ihn nein
danke danke fürs bleib da mal stehen ich
hätte nie so weggekämpft warum hast du
mir denn gesagt ich soll nichts machen
ich hätte nie wo was denn überhaupt ich
war oben ich habe doch gesagt geh den
Weg rechts runter auf einmal hast du
Monster gesehen ist einfach losgelaufen
die tun dir doch nicht wir waren noch
oben
ja was machst du warum sagst du denn
nicht das stimmt denn wir kämpfen soll
nein gute Lösung ja genau deswegen bin
ich jetzt auch tot ne danke danke gegen
das Schwert ist auf jeden Fall fürs
kämpfen da das was du gerade schon
gemacht hast nicht das nein nein nein
nein nein
[Musik]
hör auf
Elsa bist du noch da das war unser Pferd
[Musik]
ich habe gerade
ein Ozean Moment neben unserer Insel
gefunden
[Musik]
ah sehr gut Sandra ich habe dich gerade
beobachtet ja Leute ich hoffe euch hat
hier das Livestream Highlight Minecraft
loser also Minecraft mit Luca und Sandra
gefallen ist das getan hat dann das
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen ich bin tatsächlich
genau jetzt gerade wenn ihr das Video
sieht wenn es online geht nämlich am
Freitag hier heute gerade um 18 Uhr live
auf Twitch und Spiele wieder Minecraft
Skyblock vielleicht auch noch
Multiplayer mit Sandra schauen wir mal
kommt also gern vorbei Twitch Laser Luca
heiße ich da oder wenn ihr dieses Video
hier jemand später am Wochenende sehen
solltet folgt mir mal trotzdem noch
Twitch macht die Benachrichtigung an
dann bekommt er eine Nachricht auf Handy
wenn ich live bin können wir auf jeden
Fall nichts mehr verpassen danke euch
wir sehen uns ciao